this video is brought to you by
Squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business
check out Squarespace through the link
in the description below why do people
spy on their own allies what motivates
traitors US intelligence officials have
boiled down the motives for treason to
four possibilities in the acronym mice M
is money no explanation needed here it's
a motive as old as humankind I is
ideology this can be even more powerful
than money sometimes in the name of
misguided idealism secret agents can
turn against their own countries as in
the case of famous Soviet double agent
kim Philby
c is for compromise blackmail or
coercion and unwilling agents may be
forced to hand over secrets lest
compromising or embarrassing details are
divulged and iya is for ego the most
dangerous and unpredictable reason
playing two sides can provide excitement
and a feeling of power
today's protagonist Robert Hansen was an
FBI agent who served his country for
twenty years at the end of the Cold War
Hansen sold classified secrets to the
Soviet and Russian intelligence services
he compromised the security of his
country and he put the lives of his
colleagues in danger he realized his
mistakes and he stopped spying but
eventually he returned to his
duplicitous role with a vengeance so
what were his motives well apparently it
was a combination of money and ego but
there may have been a darker demon
lurking under the facade of Hansen who
is a devout Catholic and a father of six
so it wednesday's biographic s-- well
let's dig in and let's find out
Robert Phillip Hansen was born in
Chicago Illinois just weeks before d-day
on April the 18th 1944 on the day of his
birth his father was not there as he was
serving in the US Navy during World War
two in peacetime Hansen senior was a
police officer in the Chicago Police
Department
the old man was one he would not suffer
fools neither in the streets nor at home
as Robert grew up his father was
reported to have frequently abused him
ransom that he was a failure and would
never succeed in life after graduating
from high school Hansen attended Knox
College in Illinois where he studied
chemistry and Russian after graduation
he considered becoming a dentist but
eventually he set his eyes on completing
an MBA and then he began a career as an
accountant in 1968 Robert married his
fiancee Bernadette walked known as bonny
bonny a Catholic was born into a family
that was much wealthier than Roberts
influenced by her devotion he converted
to the same faith and joined Opus Dei an
exclusive conservative order within the
church the new couple had six children
and committed to send each one of them
to exclusive private schools in
accordance with Opus Dei tradition they
would also commit to donate a portion of
their income to the charitable works of
their parish
this tithing lifestyle it surely took
its toll on Roberts paycheck strangely
after a few years working as an
accountant he decided to enter law
enforcement which generally tends to be
a less lucrative career
regardless Hanson joined the force and
worked as a policeman in Chicago for
four years thanks to his background
Robert was placed in an elite unit
investigating corruption and
white-collar crimes after distant with
the boys in blue Robert decided he would
join those in gray the FBI at this stage
at the right TV to join the agency his
credentials as an accountants with an
MBA plus four years in the Chicago
anti-corruption Squad made him a good
fit for the agency's Financial Crimes
Division he was assigned to the
divisions headquarters in Gary Indiana
right out of the FBI Academy
but even as hands an investigator of
white-collar criminals in the Midwest he
was dreaming of something different
Hanson had grown up with a fondness of
espionage he was a huge James Bond fan
devouring Ian Fleming's books as well as
the movies for some reason he had even
opened a Swiss bank account
unfortunately if Anson double-oh-seven
remained nothing more than a number on
one of his spreadsheets Hanson though
had reasons to hope for a more exciting
assignment in 1978 he filed a transfer
request to the FBI office in New York
City one of the great spy capitals of
the world
he was assigned to the Soviet
counterintelligence analytical squad and
with this it really seemed like
adventure might be finally calling but
it wasn't so you see Hanson supervisors
described him as smart technically
proficient and analytical they marveled
that his skills with early computer
systems but they also considered them
lacking in field operations ability and
they assigned him to administrative work
this crushed its fantasies of going
undercover
chasing Soviet spies in the underbelly
of New York Hanson's job was to manage
the New York field officers
counterintelligence database he adjoins
the FBI to hunt spies but the agency
made him a glorified librarian in all
honesty though the job description
actually sounds quite cool Hanson's job
was to assemble a database of foreign
officials posted in New York who while
posing as diplomats were actually
intelligence officers spying on the
United States many of them were agents
of the main Soviet intelligence agency
the KGB or its military counterpart a
larger but less famous agency the GRU
but
this was not enough for Robert Hanssen
[Music]
at this stage
Special Agent Hansen felt wronged by the
FBI he also felt the increasing weight
of his bills piling up his growing
family needed more space and Hanson's
traditional stance required him to be
the main breadwinner requiring Bonnie to
stay at home these may have been the
reasons that pushed him to the edge of
treason for the first time in November
1979 Hansen used his growing knowledge
of Soviet operations to contact the GRU
and volunteer his services diver and
stealthy from the start Hansen concealed
his identity from his Soviet contacts
for 1979 until 1981 he left information
stolen from his departments the Soviet
counterintelligence unit in dead-drops
in exchange for a sum of money that
sources say fell somewhere between 21 to
30 thousand dollars that's about sixty
to ninety thousand dollars in today's
money dead drops are a common method
used by spies to exchange information
spy number one drops his or her messages
in an agreed hidden place behind a loose
brick on a certain Wharf for example the
spy then leaves a commonly understood
sign such as a simple chalk mark on
another place the handlers then know
that they have mail waiting and they can
pick up the bundle the Intel that Hanson
provided the Soviets was highly valuable
Hansen even revealed the name of the
Russian general Dmitri Polyakov who had
been providing information to the
Americans
Polyakov was put under surveillance by
the Russians he was eventually arrested
as a spy and executed in 1988
[Music]
the GRU experience was a positive test
for Hanson's resolve and ability he
might have continued his work for them
but in the spring of 1980 Hansen was
caught one can hide secrets from the FBI
the GRU even the KGB but not from a
spouse Bonnie found a strange letter
from the GRU - Hansen in the basement of
their house in Scarsdale New York Hansen
downplayed it and he told Bonnie that he
had been giving the Soviets junk
information to trick them into giving
him money in a later testimony Bonnie
said that she demanded that a husband go
with them to see their Roman Catholic
priest to confess they then drove to New
Rochelle to meet with Reverend Robert
Bakker Elli a priest also associated
with Opus Dei father Buki Riley came up
with a plan
if Robert gave the money from the
Soviets to charity and promised not to
spy again the priest committed to not
reporting the matter to the FBI now in
theory he shouldn't have done this
anyway as confessions are protected by
an oath of secrecy but I guess whatever
Hansen agreed Bonnie who at the time was
expecting their fourth child was greatly
relieved to this she was also determined
to hold her husband to the deal Robert
admitted that he had already spent most
of the GI you money but Bonnie insisted
that he repaid a charity the full
original amount he began to make small
payments over several years to a charity
affiliated with Mother Teresa's Catholic
organization which moved the family
quite close to bankruptcy over the
following years Bonnie kept close tabs
on Robert checking if he was making the
payments and even questioning him on
whether he was still working with the
Russians there seems to me at this point
the FBI would have maybe considered
hiring Bonnie Hansen in the early 1980s
Hansen was transferred to FBI
headquarters in Washington DC to his
colleagues in the bureau who were still
oblivious to his actual conduct he
seemed to be a model agents in office
chitchat Hansen often spoke of his
engagement with OPA stains appeared to
be a devoted Catholic and an nth
communist from 1981 it's on 1985 he
served in the budget and Soviet
analytical units at FBI headquarters he
may still have been a desk jockey but he
was one nested at the center of a web of
information flowing to and from the
Intelligence Division as one of the few
skilled computer operators Hanson's
cyber tendrils took in information from
the NSA and CIA reviewing info on the
FBI's most sensitive human asset
and technical operations against the
USSR finally Anson realized that the
best spies were not flashy James Bond's
but rather the smart men and women who
lurked in the shadows manipulating
information unnoticed and unknown in
September of 1985 Hanson returned to the
New York field office this time he
supervised the foreign
counterintelligence squad which gave him
access to a wealth of Soviet spy
information
this included the identity of the FBI
Soviet sources and informants as well as
the locations of KGB defectors in the
u.s. emboldened by his former success
with the GRU Hansen graduated to the big
leagues he was now going to spy for the
KGB and if you want to graduate you the
big leagues
protip do not join the KGB probably not
the best of moves right there but
instead take a step in the right
direction with Squarespace now maybe
you've got some idea for a website or a
business or a YouTube channel of podcast
something like that floating around in
your head and you might be thinking I
should probably do that I know I
definitely have these thoughts and the
reality is that most people just don't
do this but the only way you're gonna
know whether that's a good idea is to go
and pursue it and not knowing how to set
up a website is not an excuse so there
are no excuses available when you've got
Squarespace Squarespace allows you to
create a powerful website for whatever
you're up to you want to sell something
online yes it will do that or you want
to start a podcast yes sports podcasts
that actually got a podcast at brain
food fm our website was of course built
with Squarespace or maybe you want to
start a YouTube channel definitely worth
having a website to complement it
it all starts on Squarespace with a
beautiful template that you can
customize to your heart's content
or you can start from scratch or move
over an existing domain making
everything super easy to manage but
don't start from scratch you know just
use a template it's a lot easier no
excuses in the words of the great
philosopher LaBeouf don't let your
dreams be dreams I once you've gone
through the super easy customization
process there are no updates there are
no patches there's no tech BS to deal
with and Squarespace they also handle
all that website e stuff like I say
podcasts oh yes but also mainly Ness
social media integrations
much more also 24/7 customer support
there to help you whenever you've got a
query
Stremme head to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to Squarespace calm /by a
graphics and you'll save 10% off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
let's get back to Hanson on October the
4th 1985 Soviet diplomat evicted egg Gia
received a strange looking envelope to
his house in Alexandria Virginia dead
cow opens the envelope and found a
second sealed envelope inside a note
with instructions forbade guitar from
opening of the second envelope and
demanded he take it to his colleague
victor cherkashin it was clear to dead
child that whoever had send the envelope
was aware that he was in fact a KGB
officer of the PR line
the KGB organized his espionage
activities into distinct lines or
sections with different intelligence and
counterintelligence responsibilities the
PR collected information about political
economic and military strategic
intelligence each line of activity came
under the direction of the KGB rezident
an official member of the Soviet embassy
who was in fact to covert spy master
Shogun he was Victor's residence the
next day Decker handed over the package
to cherish in the veteran spy who also
had been a handler of older Ames the
CIA's most dangerous mole the letter
read dear mr. Chacon soon I will send a
box of documents to mr. Deng top they
are from certain of the most sensitive
and highly compartmented projects of the
US intelligence community all our
originals to aid in verifying their
authenticity
I trust that an officer of your
experience will handle them
appropriately I believe they are
sufficient to justify a $100,000 payment
to me I must warn of certain risks to
your security of which you may not be
aware your service has recently suffered
setbacks I warned that mr. Burris
yueshen mr. Sergei Motor Inn and mr.
Valery Martinov have been recruited by
our special services my identity and
actual position in the community must be
left unstated to ensure my security I
will add six you subtract 6 from stated
months days and times in both directions
of our future communications and then as
a signature a simple B Sharon had struck
goals three double agents exposed in
stroke simply by opening an envelope and
just like that Hansen had scored a
hundred grands his first letter to
changshan had also caused enormous
damage the FBI and CIA relied on yueshen
Motorin and Martin oov to spy for the US
and provides critical inside information
about Soviet espionage operations after
Hansen's led to the KGB flew each of the
spies back to Moscow and tried them for
espionage after sham trials the Soviets
executed murder in and Martin off you
should received a 15-year sentence from
1985 to 1991 Hansen handed to the KGB
some of the most important
counterintelligence and military secrets
in the hands of the US security services
by 1991 Hansen had completely
compromised the FBI's
counterintelligence database meanwhile
Hansen was counting his money at his FBI
desk laughing while the agency looked
for the mole in all of the wrong places
he could have quite easily have been
caught at this time during a visit from
her brother Mark walk Bonnie had
confided to him that she was alarmed she
had found five thousand dollars in cash
a time and feared that Robert may have
started spying for the Russians again
mark was an FBI agent himself although
based in Chicago he reported this to his
supervisors in 1990 but they didn't take
any meaningful action it's quite
surprising in the following years Robert
managed to avoid detection as he
skillfully it worked with the KGB
handlers without ever meeting them in
one occasion he slipped up speaking to a
Russian agents over a pay phone this
could have easily given him away as
presumably all Soviet embassy lines are
being tapped but again nothing happens
in general Hansen and egg tart relied on
a system of dead drops and signals in
public places for instance a piece of
adhesive tape placed on a sign in the
park in Virginia would indicate that a
package Amman placed under a small
footbridge in the park in 1991 the
Soviet Union collapsed this was bad news
for Hansen during the early 1990s KGB
veterans began to approach Western
intelligence agencies and spill the
beans on their recent operations Hansen
he became alarmed what if a Russian with
knowledge and activities signaled the
Americans to its true identity for eight
years
Hansen behaved like a Boy Scout at least
spy wise he stopped contacting the
Russians while waiting for his
inevitable arrest but again nothing
happened
so in 1999 while working as an FBI
liaison with the State Department he
fell back into bad habits and started
selling American secret
once again little did he know that a
former colleague on the other side of
the former Iron Curtain had begun doing
exactly the same thing a former KGB
agent had come across Hanson's KGB file
and contacted US intelligence with the
intention of selling it realizing the
importance of the material the u.s. paid
seven million dollars for it in 20 years
of selling classified Intel Hanson had
racked up approximately 1.4 million
dollars this Russian guy in perhaps two
months of work had made seven million
either the Americans had deeper pockets
or Hanson was a bit of a terrible
negotiator the dossiers sold to the
Americans it did not specify the moles
name evidence in the file though it
pointed to Hanson and he was put under
close surveillance from Special Agent
O'Neill a younger colleague who posed as
his assistants the nest was beginning to
close in on February 18th 2001 Hanson
was arrested in a park in Northern
Virginia after he had placed a package
at his usual deaddrop location the
evidence against him it was overwhelming
and to avoid the death penalty
Hanson confessed and agreed to be
debriefed by American intelligence
officials in May 2002 Hanson was
sentenced to life in prison
news reports claims that intelligence
agencies were not entirely satisfied
with the extent of his cooperation they
believed he was holding back information
but the government could not prove that
he had lied and wishing to avoid a
public trial
they did not void his plea agreements
Benson case it was regarded as a low
point for the FBI Hanson had been
trusted by his superiors he could have
been stopped on more than one occasion
and his betrayal had gone undetected for
years the government stated that Hanson
had been paid approximately 1.4 million
dollars during his spying career
although most of it was held in a
Russian bank account the damage Hanson
did it was catastrophic at least three
Russian double agents have been executed
or imprisoned because of him and it was
suspected that he compromised
dozens of intelligence operations for
example he had sold the information that
the Americans had dug a tunnel under the
Russian embassy in Washington to install
listening devices Hanson was
incarcerated at the Supermax federal
prison in Colorado fellow convicts
include the Unabomber
one of the Boston Marathon bombers and a
number of organized crime figures but
now
question comes - why did Hanson Petraeus
country during his sessions with
investigators Hanson claims that his
motivation had always been financial yet
some investigators believed anger about
how his father treated him as a child
triggered his need to rebel against
Authority author Eric O'Neill on the
other hand speculated that his motives
lay in his ego mania and his thirst for
adventure
the man is self told investigators what
had sparked his spying as fear and rage
fear of being a failure and fear of not
being able to provide for my family
Hanson said he felt rage towards the FBI
each time he was denied promotion he was
determined to prove that they had made a
mistake in not promoting him by pulling
off increasingly large-scale feats of
espionage Hanson was convinced that
other FBI agents lacked his commitment
to the bureau and the bureau in his view
was not fighting the Russians in the
right way as reporters dug deeper into
the case more disturbing psychological
demons started to emerge
friends of Hanson told journalists that
he had exhibited eccentric behavior
which included an obsession with
pornography and sex in general Lesley
Stahl from CBS reported that Hanson had
taken in the habit of sending nude
pictures of his wife to a friend of his
he even posted sexually explicit online
stories about Bonnie on the Internet
Henson got to the point of inviting his
friend to watch a live stream of him
having sex with Bonnie on a secretly
installed CCTV system Bonnie she knew
nothing about any of this Hanson's
erratic behavior it escalated including
numerous visits to strip clubs where he
tried to convert strippers to
Catholicism psychiatrist Alan Silurian
was hired and later fired by Hanson's
defense team to examine him according to
doctor Silurian spy for the Soviets for
the devoutly religious Hansen was a way
to escape those sexual problems
he stated Hanson's espionage was an
escape from his sexual demons when he
found himself in exciting dangerous
positions such as espionage and spying
he found that his demons slowed down he
is driven by demons by thoughts unwanted
thoughts doctor Silurian who spent 30
hours interviewing Hanson concluded that
the double agents was not immoral he was
simply an ill man suffering from a
severe psychological disorder of a
sexual nature who could find respite
from his torments only by putting
himself in risky situations
in 2007 Special Agent O'Neil
instrumental in Hanson's capture worked
with director and screenwriter Billy Ray
on the film breach a realistic portrayal
of the last year of Hanson's career
author Eric O'Neill published gray day
in 2013 also about Hanson's story in
which he is depicted as America's first
cyber spy Spy is secret agents the
intelligence community is always going
to capture our imagination when the
activities appear to be outside of the
boundaries of accepted morality so what
can lead a man to sell and betray his
colleagues and the security of this
country if you look at the mice set of
motives most of the time that can be
because of money or a true belief and
lofty ideals or maybe he has been
blackmailed and strong-arms or maybe
it's just down to one's ego and the need
to feed it Hanson's betrayal ultimately
may have been down to his ego but not as
a way to satisfy it rather as a way to
placate those obsessions that he could
not control so he hints if it's another
mole in our video today please let us
know if you'd like to hear the story of
another double agent we can definitely
make more of these comment below please
do also like and subscribe to this
channel when you're subscribing please
do hit the bell we put out videos four
times a week so you'll get notified
about those when we do if you hit that
bell and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]